ah come on man cheer up things can't be
that bad you're a fish that gets to lie
in the sand all day
you're a stargazing that's actually your
name though really it should be see pug
because let's face it you look like a
little water knob anyway you're looking
at one of the most remarkable fishes in
the ocean the stargazers job is bearing
itself in the sand and lying very still
as you can see but don't let the
inactivity fool you the stargazer has a
strike like you wouldn't believe in a
split second it opens its mouth spinning
a vacuum that sucks in unwitting victims
like fish and crustaceans and worms but
all this lying around does leave it a
bit vulnerable to its own pet owners but
it has that covered too you can't see it
but it has venomous spines on its fins
and can shock just like an electric eel
which is to say do not touch the
stargazer it all adds up to one
seriously formidable fish that
nevertheless looks like it just realized
it left the oven on but don't worry
little buddy it happens to the best of
us